brights movement what a demand Forex
slave reparations
she'll be interviewed by Juan Williams
senior correspondent at National Public
Radio afterwards
every Sunday at 6:00 and 9:00 p.m.
Eastern on book TV on c-span to
[Music]
President Clinton appointed Louis Freeh
to director of the FBI in 1993 mr. free
details of eight years on the job and
his difficult relationship with the
White House his new memoir my FBI he
spoke about it recently at the Union
League club in Chicago for about 40
minutes I want to tell you a little bit
about our speaker today Louis Freeh was
born in Jersey City New Jersey graduated
Phi Beta Kappa from Rutgers College in
1971 he received a JD degree from
Rutgers law school in 74 and an LLM
degree in criminal law from New York
University Law School in 1984 he was a
first lieutenant in the United States
Army Reserve he served as an FBI special
agent from 1975 to 81 in the New York
City field office and at FBI
headquarters in Washington in 1981 he
joined the United States Attorney's
Office for the Southern District of New
York as an Assistant United States
Attorney subject subsequently held
positions there as chief of the
organized crime unit deputy United
States Attorney and associate United
States Attorney in July of 91 former
President George Bush appointed mr. free
as a United States District Court Judge
for the Southern District of New York
while serving in this position he was
nominated to be the director of the FBI
by President Clinton on July 20th 1993
he was confirmed by the Senate on August
6th and was sworn in as director on
September 1st of 93 and his career as a
civil servant he's been recognized by
several occasions for his exemplary
accomplishments in 87 and 91 I received
the Attorney General's Award for
servus the second-highest annual honor
given by the Department of Justice other
commendations include the John Marshall
award for preparation of litigation
awarded annually by the Attorney General
and the federal law Enforcement Officers
Association award he is now vice
chairman and general counsel at MBNA the
credit card service giant and he and his
wife Maryland and this is the most
distinguishing characteristic he and his
wife Marilyn have six sons and they live
in Wilmington Delaware it's great
pleasure to introduce to you Lois Creek
[Applause]
thank you very much Jenny for that
introduction and thank you all for your
welcome it's honored to be back here I
was here several years ago the socks
weren't doing as well that day as I
remember but congratulations and I know
it's a very exciting time for the city
and for this institution really a
venerable institution of knowledge and
debate and interaction and I'm very very
honored to be here I want to talk a
little bit about what I wrote not so
much for the books purposes but really
just because that's the subject of what
I would talk about had I not written the
book and right before I came here I
stopped across the street to the FBI
office I was really honored that I was
asked to come by and I got the privilege
of speaking to many of my former
colleagues Rob grant we were introduced
to and it was wonderful just to see
people and again be able to thank them
for their work and their sacrifices and
I think that's why I wrote the book I
didn't want to write it when I left
Washington but I thought to tell my
story but really to tell the story of
those men and women it was important
that we do that Saarinen I know was on a
dais in Washington we honored Peter pace
the new chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff and general pace brought with him
to the dinner about 10 or 12 young
soldiers officers enlisted with horrific
wounds from Iraq loss of limbs and
wheelchairs and he's a very very booming
event but it reminded everybody there of
the you know the price of freedom and
the sacrifice that those young men and
women have made in their their their
predecessors in our military services
but also the men and women of law
enforcement
I just can't tell you how proud I am of
them and how every day in ways mostly
unreported and unsung you know their
dedication their courage and the
sacrifices that they make in their
families it really was a privilege to be
at the FBI as long as I was and to be
able now to watch him and appreciate
them you know the book is really it's
really a personal story I know the media
has focused on
24 pages in there and I understand that
that's how how it works but it's really
a story about me and I talk a lot about
my family in there I mean one of the
best memories I have of Washington and
actually President Clinton was when I
was nominating we went to the Rose
Garden and of course my wife and I'm at
the perennial debate you know should we
bring the four young boys with us or not
and of course we did we weren't going to
miss the occasion so right before the
nomination I was in the Oval Office with
the president and we were looking
outside and I'm sure you've had that
experience but we sense something was
going on I sense something's going on I
nearly knew it was my kid but I
pretended to be cool about it because I
hadn't been nominated yet so I got out
there the president introduced me very
gracious wonderful introduction and I
notice in the front row one of my son's
is completely wet and my wife my solid
the brave Irish American wife's for the
huge threshold is looking at me saying
we shouldn't have brought the kids so I
know right away something happens I
think what happened is right before the
ceremony he was six then my six-year-old
is looking into this pond you ever go to
the Rose God be very careful there's a
pond right in the middle and the
three-year-old comes up behind and then
just dumps him into the pool
Secret Service run around and everybody
is very very commotion abut I talk about
that a lot of the books because it's an
important part of what I did and then
being an FBI agent the best job I ever
had I just told my colleagues as being
25 year old aged in New York working
organized crime cases
I couldn't believe people paid me to go
to work every day I was there for a very
short period of time and my supervisor
said would you like to be an undercover
agent
I said why I said this is great I've
only been here about eight weeks and I'm
going to be an undercover agent and in
those days we didn't prepare our
undercover agents as carefully you know
there weren't any psychological
screenings or anything like that but I
had a great job what do I have to do I
said this is wonderfully so well you
have to join a health club this jelton
health club on scam Mahorn Street in
Brooklyn Heights and workout everyday I
said to myself this can't be true this
is just
so anyway my job as it turns out my job
was to surveil one Michael Clemente
Michael Clemente was then about 75 years
old he's a captain in the Genovese
family and Mike had managed to
corruptly control the leadership of one
of the longshoremen locals and by that
control could extort money out of the
shipping companies which was a lucrative
racket for the monsters and my job was
to go down to the health club and watch
them the reason I had to watch him is at
78 Michael had been arrested numerous
times mostly by the FBI and he was
taking countermeasures very active
countermeasures to avoid being arrested
again so what he would do is he wouldn't
take money from anybody anymore unless
they were standing nation with him in
the sauna of the shelf at health club so
I realized my job was to hang around the
locker and stare it up all morning and
men would come into the locker
businessmen take off their clothes and
they would take a white envelope into
the sauna room and give it to him and my
job was to relay to the agents outside
that you know Big Mike had just been
paid and could they identify the payor
so we could then use them as a witness
so this was very good and then at one
point mr. Clemente comes over and talks
to me no one had prepared me for talking
wrong and he said what do you do Katie
says you're here every day and I said
well I said Mr Clemente I said this was
the the Franciscan nuns of Peekskill I
didn't really want a lie even though
another cover agent I know was supposed
to line so I said well I'm a lawyer but
I don't really have a job as a lawyer
which was true and he says well he's and
he says I know all the judges down here
he says I'll get one to hire you
and the judges actually worked out in
the Shelton Health Club they were very
embarrassed later on so anyway I put him
off with the the point of the story was
weeks later you know Michael goes the
way of organized crime he gets arrested
and we're in the courtroom Foley Square
us courthouse famous courthouse in
Manhattan and Mike's being arraigned and
I'm this was actually going to be in the
court room where I became a judge many
years later so Mike's in the back of the
courtroom I'm in the wall of the
courtroom with the would be was a
prosecutor and my quad mates got Mike
Mike's making a lot of noise he's trying
to get my attention and part of the
noise and the handcuff says he's waving
and yelling kid hey kid kid so I'm
ignoring him you know when you want to
ignore somebody you just don't want to
meet them so finally his lawyer comes up
to me very prominent organized crime
lord any sense to me
you see if I ask you questions are you
an FBI agent and I said yes I said I'm
an FBI agent and he's shifty sugars head
he says you know he says I've been
telling my goal morning he says you're
probably an FBI agent and he insisted
that I come up and tell the judge to let
the kid go because he had nothing to do
with it
I was I was very very privileged to be
to be the FBI director and in the
background of that for me was after
being a prosecutor for ten years I went
on to the federal bench
I wasn't politically active or connected
I had been a career prosecutor and for a
lawyer obviously what's the what a great
thrill to become a federal judge and it
was it was a true honor and you know
part of being an American part of being
in our great country remember very
shortly after I became the judge I got a
case you know the cases come in randomly
they were signed to sake this was a
civil case was a title seven
discrimination case against a company
very prominent Wall Street brokerage and
I saw the name I started and I
remembered my mother my italian-american
mother telling me a story when I was
about 12 years old and story was how
graduating from high school in the Bronx
she went down at a friend's invitation
to interview for a job and went to this
company and she was very very excited
about the interview was her first job
she was 17 years old and they
interviewed her and they said at the end
of the day we liked you very much miss
Kingkiller but we can't hire you because
you're Italian so you know you remember
a story like that you know somebody was
mean to your mom even if you were 12 and
you're hearing it so it was the same
company
it was the same company and you know I
immediately recused myself and sent it
to another judge but I said you know
what a what an incredible thing that you
know only in a country as great as
merger could this happen you know now
you know 20 years later the kid is the
judge and he's got the company's case
you know a lot of things like that that
that are remarkable anyway I didn't want
the job as FBI director and when it was
offered to me I turned it down and the
reason I did that is because I really
didn't want to leave the bench and I
want to leave where we living up in
Westchester County and I'd always wanted
to be a judge and it was it was just a
remarkable job but I agreed to take the
job
because of the affection I had for the
people that I had worked with there for
six years starting in 1975 but I came to
Washington as a political stranger and
you know why was I asked to take the job
a job that I turned down and it's a very
important story in terms of what I had
to do when I took the job the president
was wanting to nominate a friend of his
from Oxford named na Stearns very very
excellent lawyer now a judge up in
Boston and wanted to make him the FBI
director they were all set to do the
nomination and then travelgate happened
you may remember travelgate the first of
many things that started to happen down
there and the allegation and travelgate
was that the president was using the FBI
to force the career people out of the
travel office so he could put his
relatives in and his senior people told
him you cannot appoint your friend as
FBI director under those circumstances
and the president got a little bit
annoyed a little bit exasperated and
said well you know find me a perfect
stranger and they found me I came there
with that with that lack of relationship
and what it gave me was a tremendous
amount of Independence it was a job I
didn't think I didn't wanna turned it
down and I made no effort to be
appointed it wasn't I mean that's
anybody to write a letter or make a
phone call so I took the job with
complete independence as I assumed
office I was there a very short period
of time so short in fact that I had not
unpacked most of my boxes in my office
most of my boxes were still full and one
of my senior guides came in one day and
he said I need to brief you on a case
it's called the Madison Savings and Loan
case and I said okay you know brings me
on the case so he briefed me on the case
I interrupted him and I said you just
told me were conducting a criminal
investigation of the president in that
xscape and he said no no he said it's
just an SNL case and I said well tell me
again and I interrupted him again I said
no you just told me we're conducting a
criminal investigation the president and
that conflict because was a conflict
really persistent and actually enlarged
itself over the period of a
here we were continuously investigating
allegations and most of them are only
allegations and they dent in fairness
result in charges or things like that
but in the process of investigating them
it created a very unique situation
between the FBI director and the
President of the United States no FBI
director in a hundred years there's only
been six of them by the way in 100 years
because one of them stayed for almost
five decades no director had ever been
in that position except L Patrick gray
who unfortunately did not take care of
the responsibilities when he was
required to do that investigation so you
know that was that was the conflict that
was created and I thought it was a very
difficult responsibility to discharge I
had to protect the integrity of the
investigation I had to protect the FBI
and had to protect the president and
early on one of the things I noted in
there was the White House as they do
with all senior presidential appointees
they send you passes the pass to the
White House that lets you come and go
without signing in and I sent it back to
the White House with a very polite note
for the very simple purpose that I
wanted to make sure that whenever I was
in the White House there was a record of
it to protect again myself and FBI but
also the president because of the fact
that I was the chief investigator and he
was the subject of the criminal
investigation and I found out years
later he was very angry about that he
got very upset he saw it as a personal
hostile act when it wasn't it was the
process it was the process of making
sure that what we did was fair thorough
but also we preserve the integrity of it
and I think that was really the biggest
criticism that I had I don't think he
understood the process the process of
the rule of law that requires in some
situations for people to deal with those
conflicts and resolve them in a manner
that protects the integrity of what's
being done and avoids the perception of
unfairness the perception of favoritism
and that would that was a great great
challenge I don't think it distracted
the president from his
responsibilities I don't ever claim that
and I don't think it's extracted the FBI
from its responsibilities and one of the
I wanna make sure I leave some time for
some questions one of the main
challenges that we had during the course
of those eight years almost eight years
what you know was what we call the war
on terrorism I just want to speak very
very briefly about that if you go back
to October of 1983 to Beirut Lebanon we
just mark the anniversary 243 Marines
was killed if you remember by a vehicle
bombing performed by Hezbollah Hezbollah
has and is now an agent of the Iranian
government and has been before September
11 the main killer of Americans and
other people to that Americans all over
the world they fomented radical
fundamentalist and violent war against
the United States and have killed the
Navy divers station Chiefs Colonels
tourists soldiers as well as many of our
friends that war started in some ways
the own October of 1983 and continues
today our response to you know that war
was to do a number of things some of
which were very effective and some of
which I'm very proud of in terms of what
FBI agents did during that period but if
you look at the run-up to September 11
you know what were we doing in response
to al-qaeda's declaration and waging of
war against the United States and we
don't we don't blame the Marine Barracks
bombing on them but to our embassies
were destroyed in August of 1998 an
Aegis class warship the USS Cole in
October 2000 was almost sunk except for
the heroics of the crew overnight a
fatwa had been issued by bin Laden to
kill Americans anywhere the Millennium
taught us that you know whether it was
rasam heading for LAX a plan then to
think the USS Sullivan which
in January of 2000 at the same fuel pod
that the coal was sunk 10 months later a
plan at the end of millennium to murder
as many Americans and Jews and Jordan as
could be possible
the 1993 attack against the world trade
tower the two main architects were
Ramsey Yosef and colleague Sheikh
Mohammed who's one of the masterminds of
the 9/11 attack trains the you know by
al-qaeda camps the point is that there
was really no surprise coming up to
September 11 that this was an
organization that was engaging in war
against the United States we should have
been no more surprised than we were at
Pearl Harbor
you know we had broken the Japanese
naval code it was only a question of
where in the Pacific the u.s. naval
forces would be attacked it was like the
you know the news reports in the summer
of 1945 that no Allied troops had
stumbled was the word people used
stumbled upon the death camps and we
were we were shocked as a world and as a
people to learn that the Nazis had
systematically murdered millions of
millions of people but you know army
intelligence knew about that in 1941
they didn't stumble upon the camps but
for a lot of reasons during the war they
decided not to offer those poor people
any release decisions not to bond the
railheads
where people particularly in late 1944
were being put on an accelerated basis
on trains to be murdered and and pretty
much politically we made the same
decision before September 11th and it's
not a popular thing to talk about but
it's something that I want to talk about
and I talk about in my book we did not
declare war against al-qaeda until
September 11 2001 and there were things
in the 9/11 Commission I didn't agree
with but what they had I think exactly
right was their finding that neither
President Bush nor President Clinton nor
their national security advisors put the
country on a war footing before
September 11 what were we doing before
September
we do a lot of things Ramsay Yosef was
arrested by FBI agents in Pakistan
brought back to the United States tried
in convicted for the 93 world trade
tower bombing for a conspiracy to blow
up 11 u.s. airliners over the Pacific
Kazi remember who murdered the people
outside the CIA arrested by FBI agents
brought back we convicted people in the
1998 embassy bombings brought back to
New York bin Laden was indicted twice in
1998 once before the East African
bombings we put him on the top ten list
I went over to Lahore Pakistan in the
spring of 2000 to meet with President
Musharraf asking him for his assistance
in having us get custody and take bin
Laden out of Afghanistan back to the
United States and he told me he was of
no help by the way and he said he said
he had spoken to Omar mula who had
assured him that in Laden was no longer
no longer engaged in terrorism
activities the fact the matter is before
September 11th if you were a major
terrorist what you had to be concerned
about was an indictment in the Southern
District of New York and some deputy
u.s. marshal trying to serve an arrest
warrant it was not going to work you
know if we thought it was going to work
we should have had our heads examined
it's not to criticize two
administrations by the way not one but
it's to I think accurately describe
where the country was and the best
example of that for us and the FBI at
the time was the bombing of the USS Cole
if you recall October 2000 a warship the
worship of the United States almost sunk
by Al Qaeda I was on that ship
about 24 hours after the attack and I
watched young FBI agents reverently
removing the remains of those 17
soldiers and putting them on a stretcher
with a flag over it and we were
conducting an investigation we're
looking for witnesses forensics etc what
was remarkable to us then and now is
that within 48 hours after that
there was no more discussion of it it
had dropped out of the news cycle you
know our perpetually annoying news cycle
it had dropped out of it nobody in
Congress was talking about invading
Afghanistan and maybe the most
remarkable thing October 2000 was the
middle of a presidential election and in
the last presidential election maybe the
last two national securities was the
only thing anybody wanted to talk about
at that particular period nobody was
talking about Al Qaeda nobody's talking
about our embassies nobody was talking
about our 19 heroes at Cold War this was
a terrible thing that was happening but
it was happening to Americans and
military Americans for the most part
overseas and it wasn't until the you
know the horrific days they had them to
me to September 11th when when we went
to war and then what what did we do we
did what anybody and everybody by the
way for the most part at that time said
was perfectly needed and correct we
invaded Afghanistan to destroy the
command and control in the leadership of
an organization that was fighting a war
against the United States
so my point and one of the things that
are talking about the last couple weeks
is you know we ought to put that into
perspective you know instead of there
trying to hold a CIA officer or an FBI
agent responsible for 9/11 I love it you
know who's responsible for 9/11 well you
know it's a big it's a big playing field
with many many actors all of whom had
opportunities to do things and the fact
of the matter was my opinion we didn't
have the political will in the United
States to do on September 10th what we
did on September 11th if a president or
somebody in Congress had had stood up
and said I think we have to invade
Afghanistan then young men and women
over there to fight I think they would
have been roundly denounced politically
it would there would have been no
support for it that was my that's my
opinion and I think we have to we have
to put that in perspective and you know
not do what we did after Pearl Harbor we
took an agro me court-martialed when we
blamed him for Pearl Harbor now as if
the rest of the country the country who
knew the military and the political
leaders then
the stand that the Empire of Japan was
just waiting and looking for a spot to
attack so you know I think it's a
valuable discussion to have where we're
very prone as Americans know to to sort
of blame like to have a solution who's
responsible for this
the famous you know refrain in
Washington when something goes wrong
who's responsible for this well you know
I think if we're talking about terrorism
we're talking about a dynamic in the
history and and I think it's a
perspective that's very very important
we certainly you know should not do that
in an unfair way that takes the heroes
of our country whether they are in
service overseas or across the street in
the FBI and doing their job they talked
a little bit to water but I'll be happy
to answer some questions for you yeah
Jenny I'd like you to talk a little bit
about an incident that occurred after
you left the FBI and started to work for
MBNA and that involved a helicopter can
you talk a little bit about the story
yeah yeah we had a it was it was a
really miraculous event the only way I
could describe it in June of this year
six of my colleagues the senior
leadership for the bank were in New York
actually negotiating a transaction which
resulted in the sale of our bank and the
helicopter again six of my colleagues
including our CEO takes off from the
East 34th Street Airport on the way back
to Wilmington I was supposed to be on
that helicopter the last minute myself
and the lawyer for the other side had to
do some other things the helicopter goes
about 90 feet into the air loses power
crashes into the East River the tail of
the helicopter breaks off and the cabin
in 25 seconds of skills with water so
these six men or underwater in a
helicopter cabin with the door closed
and they got out I mean it was just
absolutely amazing none of them had been
you know trained in
kind of a of an event they got out they
help each other out one of them I
mentioned in my in the book who was
probably the worst swimmer with a
medical condition stayed there and
pulled two other guys out of the
helicopter before he left them before it
sank it was just an absolutely
incredible event and our Testaments to
human courage and you know people
helping each other when would it happen
and the other remarkable thing about it
and I was happy that it happened in New
York City even in the FBI
nobody wanted anything bad to happen on
the other hand if something bad happened
we used to hope it would be in New York
City because that's the place with and
I'm prejudiced I know they just they
doing such an incredible job when the
helicopter crashed there was a guy on
the East River Drive he delivered his
blood friend mr. Lopez delivers bread
that's he had a destructive zone of
breath he saw the helicopter crashing
stopped the truck he jumped in the river
and he pulled one of my colleagues out
and then he insisted on going getting
back in the truck the EMT guys have you
got to go to Bellevue you got to be no
no I'll be fired if I don't get back in
my truck he drove away he drove away and
we found it we honored them about a
month ago with his family you know
fishing boat happened to be there it was
it was the summer people around the
water it was like you know many things
that happened that otherwise it would
have been it would have been just
horrific
thank you for asking that yes sir
Homeland Security now taking over all of
these investigations sure my feelings on
Homeland Security you know I had I had
questions about the you know the
efficacy of putting that infrastructure
together I think I've come to the point
where I think it's probably a prudent
and smart thing to do and my cure dog
who was a prosecutor with me in New York
for many years a very very dear friend
you couldn't find a better secretary to
do that job the challenge there is the
integration of 22
you still have 22 agencies the synergies
that you need and the seamless as
particularly with respect to obtaining
information and then analyzing it
properly and acting on it it's a huge
challenge it would be the equivalent of
you know a big company taking over 22
small companies and anybody who's done
corporate work the integration the
execution of that is enormous ly
difficult and that's what's being done
and you know the people who are much
more knowledgeable about it who say this
this will work but we have to be patient
and in that process you know we're going
to overreact sometimes we're maybe going
to overreact to a threat and we simply
afraid to do that and worried about the
criticism I think the overall plan is a
good one I think we have to really work
hard to do that integration yes sir
first of all thank you very much for
your service secondly two questions one
is it correct that Osama bin Laden was
offered to the United States by Sudan in
the late 1990s and that offer was turned
down and secondly what do you expect to
come out from the CIA report regarding
able danger yeah no he was never offered
to the United States with respect to
able danger you know I don't know I am
intensely interested in that and as I
said I didn't agree with everything of
the 9/11 Commission said I am very
interested and I have a lot of questions
about you know at least what's been
reported in the media specifically that
you know two very very credible military
officers assigned to that unit and
apparently other people now who have
corroborated that story identified by
name and picture Mohamed Atta in 2000
has a al Qaeda operative in the United
States seems to me like that would be a
very relevant piece of any post 9/11
inquiry and I think it should be I don't
know what the ramifications are I would
say however that you know there's a
difference in what I used to do and what
many of these men and women here
- exceptionally better there's a
difference between what we call tactical
intelligence and you know general
strategic intelligence tactical
intelligence is Khalid Sheikh Mohammed
is getting on a plane in Doha and he's
flying to Bahrain this afternoon and
we'd like to get our hands on KSM and
miss them that time because he was
tipped off by one of the country's
tactical intelligence is this is a
picture of a man named Mohammed Azza
who's an al Qaeda operative in the
United States would the FBI have been
able to use that information absolutely
and I don't know what's going to come
out of the inquiry but I know a lot of
us who were working there and many of us
who are still there are intensely
interested in that question and I am
heard a lot of answers or consistent
explanations by the 9/11 Commission by
the way you already S ones anything
that's a criminal justice system in the
war on terrorism yes is there role for
the criminal justice system in the war
on terrorism absolutely you know in a
war you use as many weapons as you have
one of the weapons we have is the
criminal justice system that is able to
identify and disable terrorists it's
able to exploit the information of
develop witnesses get people to
cooperate obtain evidence very very
effective and you know as I said I'm
very proud of the cases major terrorism
cases that the FBI did during this whole
period it is not however you know the
unilateral solution for an organization
that is a military organization capable
of blowing up ships and embassies you
can't fight a war against an enemy like
that you know with with grand juries and
subpoenas and judicial orders but there
is a part of that conflict and a part of
that process that is very amenable to
that work we just we didn't do
everything we could have done before
September 11th on the other side of that
yeah Danny
you're talking about they're not being
adequate resources allocated to the FBI
during your term has that changed if it
has changed and now are they adequate
now yes
well look everybody Washington complains
about resources and you know I certainly
was one of them and I felt that in
counterterrorism particularly you know
we didn't have what we needed to get the
job done and Congress was generous to us
we doubled the number of people work in
the program we triple the resources we
put together a counterterrorism
divisions the FBI we reorganized that we
didn't get anywhere near the resources
that we wanted since September 11th
there's been a great addition of
resources but there are only about 1400
more agents now than when I left office
and as I testified before the Joint
Intelligence Committee I don't think
that's sufficient 1,400 more agents to
focus on counterterrorism as we've made
it a priority but also I my day is to do
the very important work that only the
FBI does civil rights cases public
corruption cases we have examples of
that close by major organized crime case
and major white-collar crime cases now
what happened after September 11 we took
you know hundreds and hundreds of FBI
resources and put them in
counterterrorism but we took them out of
these other vital programs I don't think
that's smart as I testified before the
committee I said why don't we do
something really innovative and creative
give the FBI's 5,000 more agents and you
know 1,400 is great not enough to do all
the things that they do so well I need
to do again that's my opinion
yes ma'am
whereas
yeah as long as I'm not director I'm
okay with it that's right where we might
respect is better prepared to prevent a
9/11 one I think we're much better I
think we're much smarter I think we've
got much more capability overseas
domestically than we ever had before
we've got authorities like the Patriot
Act which I know people thought was
controversy but let me tell you another
example of something which I thought was
controversial if if before the Patriot
Act and before September 11th by the way
bin Laden was going to hold a rally in
the Sheep Meadow of Central Park and
announced his fought want an FBI agent
couldn't go and stand in the crowd it
was okay because there were guidelines
many many years old that prevented an
FBI agent from doing that and the
guidelines by the way we're actually put
in place to deal with some very serious
and illegal FBI conduct 25 years ago so
we're doing things a little bit better a
little bit smarter I think I think one
of the reasons you know we have not seen
the major attack in the United States
since September 11th is is that we've
gotten better at this we've exploited a
lot of overseas information and
witnesses that we never had access to
before
things that they got off hard drives in
Afghanistan and from the briefings of
prisoners and detainees have been
extremely valuable but you know this is
a very very vulnerable country as any
free country is and by the way as part
of that that we want to we want to
preserve but you know we've hardened up
federal buildings airports it took us
about an hour to get out of Philadelphia
last night you know and we all accept
that it's necessary but you know my
question is when I see I see a truck
delivering boxes to the vendors on the
other side of the security thing and I
wonder whose check
mmm and nobody'd ever really give me a
good explanation that our seaports and
the problem with someone who's willing
to die to attack us you've got you've
got you've got soccer stadiums you've
got malls you've got schools I mean you
saw what happened to the country or the
Capital Region a couple years ago with
with the snipers I mean it it almost
shut the area down if people were
holding their kids home from school they
were hiding behind their cars and
they're getting gas the balls were
deserted and that was two guys with a
mail-order rifle shooting people
randomly out of the back of a car so
we're very susceptible we're very prone
to that on the other hand you look at
the the courage of people whether it's
you know 9/11 in Washington or
Pennsylvania or New York and you know
we're very resilient and I think we're
doing things better
one more question yeah um during your
tenure as a director you spent a lot of
time outside of Washington visiting
field offices talking to agents and and
you've become a very popular director of
the FBI you how do you look at that
experience is that the way you want to
be looked at your legacy to that job um
you know one of the things one of the
things I thought was most important as
director was to you know to try to be as
available and accessible as I as you
could be yeah I mean I worked very hard
at that I did I went out all the time
through our offices I visit each of our
offices about three or four times most
of it was just for mental health getting
out of Washington DC by the way but the
more important thing was to find out you
know what people were doing and I would
go to the office I would meet with every
squad I wouldn't have allowed the essays
the guys in charge of the office
couldn't come to the meeting they didn't
like this at first and I'd have a
briefing book and I'd sit with the
agents and the support people and I'd
ask them questions how are we doing you
know we had a wonderful policy we just
enunciated in Washington we think it's
brilliant and then some guy would say it
stinks laws you know it's not working
never get that feedback by the way in
Washington you know you get very
elaborate briefings with graphics and
you know they have answers to all your
questions but you don't really know
what's going on in the field unless you
get out so that was very important the
other part of it was fun
it was one of the most fun things I did
to get out and see agents spend time
with them and you know as I said if I
said recently in this book I could be
more proud of than one of the FBI I I
can't tell you how extraordinary they
are in the circumstances you know under
which they work the stress the
sacrifices they and their families make
they are really really heroes for us and
part of the fun of this is getting a
chance to see some of them and getting
to thank them again
[Applause]